they call this free syria but armed
checkpoints are scattered throughout
idlib province
there are a dozen different rebel
factions operating here
and many don't like cameras
here hts is in control of much of idlib
it's an alliance of jihadists who
insists they're no longer linked to
al-qaeda
they have a strict code of conduct and
i'm told to dress accordingly
look at the black sign to your right on
the lamppost we spot several
telling women they should be veiled and
others banning smoking
a few miles away from where we are a
group of men are accused of being is
bombers
a picture by the hts media wing shows
the six men
saying their final prayers the next
picture is taken after the shooting
is still operating in parts of this area
but the rebels are now focused on one
last big battle
they're building their defenses with
diggers
and by hand preparing sandbags and
trenches
the civilians are not at all convinced
they've been living under these
conditions some of them for years
moving from place to place fleeing from
bombing and shelling and trying to get
to safety this is the last rebel holdout
and now this is under threat the regime
wants idlib
under its control and those in the
middle are terrified
this family of 16 has moved four times
already
we are afraid we are afraid of
everything she says
her sister says we don't know what to do
with the children
or where to go for safety
got nowhere else to go now the
population here has roughly doubled to
nearly 3 million with all the displaced
people
they struggle under tents with few
facilities
many have never known any other life
than war
just the word regime terrifies us
because they kill
children and women and no one cares
about what's happening to us
this clinic serves 90 000 people many of
whom have lost relatives or bear the
scars of war
this little boy lost his father in
aleppo
we are living in a big prison
no water no electricity no
we are facing hard conditions
the un and human rights groups have
warned of an humanitarian disaster if
the regime tries to take idlib by force
the people sheltering here can only
await their fate
alex crawford sky news in idlib province